Lieutenant Governor Dan Patrick Governor
um I've already gotten text messages
from people who are concerned and
hearing that that this is just what
Biden wants he wants something to
trigger something that will end up you
know ending up in some type of violence
involving States versus the federal
government are you concerned about that
given how this is
changing I'm not concerned Laura the big
mistake the Biden Administration could
make would be confronting law
enforcement or our military our National
Guard at our border at this park when
we're actually doing the job that the
American people want so if they come
down and create a situation all of
America already knows now they will
clearly see that the Democrats are
willing to take on a state that is
operating ating under the our
constitutional right to protect our
people and protect this country I don't
think even Biden will make that mistake
we're not looking for a confrontation
we're looking for them to do their damn
job and protect the lives of Texans and
Americans and protect the borders in
this country and for every person that's
died of a fentanyl overdose for every
person that's been murdered by MS-13 for
every Law Enforcement Officers been
killed in the line of duty because these
people across the border that death is
on the hands of Joe Biden and this
Administration and his policies On the
Border they should not come and confront
us they should just let us do our
job do you welcome National Guard
members from other states are you
encouraging them to come join you and if
so for what
purpose so Laura we've had cooperation
from other states we've had National
Guard from other states and Texas will
take all the help we can get it shows a
unified America it shows a unified group
of Republican Governors who want to
protect this country but it has to be
organized it's got to you know we we we
don't want to have thousands of people
show up tomorrow we want to work with
their departments their National Guard
but in terms of asking for help we're
glad to have the backing of these Brave
bold Governors and Lieutenant Governors
and senators in the Republican party
around this country who realize they're
willing to come to the aid of Texas
because they know we're holding the line
would it would it take the form of of
perhaps confronting border patrol who
are trying to get into certain areas
would it would it be putting up U more
of that uh razor wire or other types of
obstructions at the border what exactly
would they be
doing um you're talking in terms of the
National Guard yeah I'm sorry yeah well
we have lots of jobs on the border for
people to do we're busy at work every
day remember our border
uh Laura for folks who don't know is
longer than the distance between Atlanta
and Portland Main it's 1250 some miles
and so we need people everywhere but let
me tell you what we're doing the job if
Joe Biden will get out of our way we'll
do the job we'll secure the Border we
don't need them and and also let me say
something about this border patrol
border patrol works with us the rank and
file every day we work together like
this it's Joe Biden that wants to come
in and split us apart he wants this conf
for what reason we're doing the job at
the state park they have no reason to be
there they got 1,200 miles to cover
we're doing the job they're try they're
trying to make this a fight we're trying
to protect our border we're trying to
protect American lives and Texas lives
that's what we're trying to do and he's
trying to turn into a political battle
and turn into a fight with our state
well Don't Mess with
Texas um Lieutenant Governor Dan Patrick
thank you as always hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else